اكد رئيس خليه الاعلام الامني في العراق
اللواء تحسين الخفاجي ان استهداف سياره
تابعه للحشد الشعبي يعتبر تقويضا
للتفاهمات مع الولايات المتحده وصف القصف
في بيان بانه عدوان واضح وخرق للسياده
العراقيه كما اضاف الخفاجي ان السلطات
العراقيه تحمل الجانب الامريكيه وقوات
التحالف المسؤوليه عن التداعيات التي تهدد
امن وسلامه
البلاد
معنا من بغداد مراسل الجزيره عبد الفتاح
فايد عبد الفتاح اذا تداعيات هذه الضربات
وكيف تتفاعل ردود الفعل حولها حتى
الان بالفعل سهام مازالت ردود الفعل
تتوالى بادانه واستنكار هذه الهجمات التي
تعتبرها انتهاكا للسياده العراقيه وعدوانا
سافرا على العراق را ومجرم كما قال الكثير
من
قيادات الاحزاب والكتل السياسيه العراقيه
وايضا القيادات في الحشد الشعبي العراقي
الذين وصفوا هذه الهجمات بانها تهديد خطير
لامن وسلامه العراق وايضا تهديد لامن
المنطقه برمتها ووجهوا دعوات الى الحكومه
العراقيه بضروره التصدي الحازم والحاسم
لمثل لمثل تلك الهجمات التي يعتبرونها
انتهاكا للسياده العراقيه
حتى الان سهام ما زالت قوات الامن
العراقيه تكثف حضورها بقوه امام المداخل
الرئيسيه للمنطقه الخضراء وخاصه عند الجسر
المعلق المؤدي الى السفاره الامريكيه وسط
دعوات للتظاهر في تلك المنطقه ايضا في
الرابعه من عصر هذا اليوم بالتوقيت المحلي
في العاصمه العراقيه بغداد سيكون تشييع
جثامين الضحايا الذين سقطوا في هذه
الهجمات التي وقعت بالامس في منطقه المشتل
شرق العاصمه العراقيه بغداد هذا التشييع
سيكون امام مقر اعلام الحشد الشعبي في
شارع فلسطين بالقرب من ساحه الطيران في
منطقه منطقه ايضا شرق بغداد وهي قريبه على
المنطقه التي ح حصل فيها هذا الاستهداف
ليله الامس ما زالت ردود الافعال تتوالى
من الكتل السياسيه وايضا من خليه الاعلام
الامني من هيئه العمليات المشتركه التي
حملت الجانب الامريكي مسؤوليه هذه
الاعتداءات ومسؤوليه
تقويض المفاوضات الجاريه بين الجانبين
ومسؤوليه تقويض ايضا كل التفاهمات بين
الجانبين كذلك هناك دعوات من قبل قياديين
في البرلمان العراقي لضروره عقد جلسه
طارئه للبرلمان لضروره البحث واتخاذ قرار
حاسم
باخراج القوات الامر امريكيه من العراق
والقوات الاجنبيه عموما من البلاد وما
زالت بالتاكيد ردود الافعال تتوالى هناك
دعوات من حركه النجباء وكثير من حركات
المقاومه الاسلاميه في العراق الى ضروره
ان يكون هناك ردا حاسما والقول بان عدم
الرد سوف يكون مبررا للقوات الامريكيه كما
يقولون لاستمرار هجماتها المكثفه على
العراق وانتهاك سيادته واجوائه خاصه وان
هذا الهجوم قد وقع في قلب العاصم العراقيه
بغداد وامام مقرات امنيه تابعه لهيئه
الحشد الشعبي التي يقولون ان هيئه عسكريه
وامنيه تابعه للقائد العام للقوات المسلحه
العراقيه وبالتالي هو انتهاك خطير وغير
مبرر للسياده العراقيه سهام نعم عبد
الفتاح فايد مراسل الجزيره كنت معنا من
بغداد شكرا جزيلا لك